while heavy rain and severe weather
impact the eastern two-thirds of the
country parts of the West are gripped by
record-breaking heat it is hot with a
capital H Lonnie Quinn that's chief
weather caster of our New York station
that's W CBS is here with how it's all
connected
Lonnie good morning well good morning
you get on good morning everybody you
know look everything's connected in our
atmosphere the big rain that we just
showed you in Pennsylvania all due to a
low pressure system pulling in lots of
tropical moisture out west what we're
dealing with all of this heat all
because of a high pressure system and
this high and that low are connected
because they're basically just cars
stuck in a traffic jam behind that this
high-pressure system until this moves
nothing changes heat continues here in
the West low pressure continues to pull
in big rain for the East Coast look at
the numbers in terms of rainfall that
we're talking about any area shaded in
this like orange or red color that's a
half a foot or more of rain by the time
you get to the end of the work week here
in the West
our numbers are off the charts Palm
Springs today will reach 121 degrees I
mean that's a record for the date the
all-time record in Palm Springs at 123
so you're getting close there and as you
go into tomorrow
again nothing changes Wednesday's high
temperature Palm Spring 120 degrees this
is dangerous heat that even continues
into Thursday Thursday about 118 now I
talked about how the all-time record in
Palm Springs 123 degrees all-time record
ever recorded in the world really is
Death Valley at 134 so you're even
within you know I guess spitting
distance to that this is a lot of heat
but again you got to emphasize that this
is dangerous Nora wow it's just
incredible to see those temperatures
Lonnie thank you